okay the chair of the British Academy of
Film and Television Arts or BAFTA is
furious over the lack of diversity in
this year's nominations the nominees for
the UK's prestigious film awards were
announced yesterday all of the actors
you see them there
nominated are white they include Margot
Robbie and Scarlett Johansson who are
each nominated for two acting awards
this is important because the back
depicts are a major Oscars predictor the
chair of BAC this film committee told
variety quote it's just a frustration
that the industry is not moving as fast
as certainly the whole bath the team
would like it to be look I love mark
setting margot robbie was amazing in
bombshell hollywood but she's competing
against herself as Best Supporting
Actress so JLo in Hustler's Cynthia Revo
and Harry British by the way British
Eddie Murphy and Dolomites there are a
lot of options I was gonna say it's not
like they didn't have things to choose
from though so it feels so deliberate
well the bias is real dance it reminds
me of those resume tests where you take
an african-american name and a white
name same qualifications and that's a
callback one of the film critics her
name is LaRoche Rushka Ivan's a day said
it feels like you're using up spaces
that could perhaps be used for different
and more diverse performances and it's
not that the performances aren't there
and talking about the competing of
Margot Robbie I hope that's not a
foreshadowing of the Oscars I don't
think it will be no I hope so